a pesar de que la ciudad de bacmut cayó
finalmente en control de las fuerzas de
Moscú el pasado mayo después de ocho
meses de intensos de lucha la batalla
por el control de esta ciudad a pesar de
que está destruida continúa hace parte
de esa larga contraofensiva que libran
las fuerzas ucranianas a lo largo de más
de 1000 kilómetros de línea divisoria
Esta es uno de los focos de esa
contraofensiva lo que están buscando es
rodear la ciudad y volver a recuperar su
control estamos en una población a 10
kilómetros del centro de
ha sido eje de la lucha por el para
liderar esa batalla para controlar o
liderar o liberar la ciudad estamos es
atacada permanentemente por las fuerzas
de Moscú aquí nos cuentan las
autoridades que el 99% de las
edificaciones ha quedado destruida por
lo menos los edificios y el 85%
viviendas civiles están prácticamente
también afectadas aún así hay 10% de la
población que ha decidido quedarse a
pesar de que no tienen agua No tienen
electricidad y son atacados
permanentemente con diferente clase de
artillería que lanzan las fuerzas de
Moscú aquí se sienten los ataques
permanentemente aún así para muchos de
ellos la mayoría mayores es mejor opción
quedarse en lo que ellos conocen como su
casa Así que todavía las organizaciones
humanitarias siguen distribuyendo ayuda
en este lugar que está prácticamente
rodeado por los militares pero también
nos cuentan aquí las fuerzas que están
ubicadas las fuerzas ucranianas que han
logrado avanzar en diferentes flancos
alrededor de bakmuth que van bastante
adelante y que su objetivo será
recuperarla a pesar de que lo que están
haciendo las fuerzas rusas es crear una
gran línea de defensa alrededor de la
ciudad no son tres líneas de defensa
como las que hacen en saporilla sin
embargo en el momento que logren romper
esa Barrera esperan poder volver a
recuperar esta ciudad que se ha
convertido en un símbolo de la defensa
de Ucrania